dans l'esprit la martinique gourmande
pour moi c'est déjà une petite partie de
la france et en plus ça fait partie
comme on vit à montréal ou au québec du
sud et je trouve que da martinique on
n'en parle pas encore assez on parle
beaucoup des autres îles les autres
karibe mais pas assez là de la
martinique et donc j'ai justement un
petit faible pour la martinique
je savais enseigner
qu'est ce qui était très du terroir très
traditionnel aussi par rapport à la
cuisine d'antan aussi martin crise les
produits les provenances ainsi que les
épices bien sûr qu'ils sont très très
présente en martinique
donc bien sûr de ça j'ai voulu créer un
menu par rapport à cela
donc est enneigée du 10 août quand même
trouver toutes les épices pour faire
sans que ce soit le plus typique
possible donc c'est quand même le bois
d'un on a les épicentres interne à
l'écurie curcuma le merci vous avez la
muscade
vous en avez plein finalement oui on
arrive si c'est pas tout à fait les
mêmes
on peut toujours s'arranger mais on
arrive assez facilement parce que tout
le monde se fait alimenté par l'amérique
du sud aussi
et donc est certainement certains
endroits on peut aussi avoir des
produits des îles
des clients qui sont même au bout
de dix ans des amis j'aurais poussé
d'aller en martinique au mieux d'aller
sur des îles voisines et ils ont adoré
justement la martinique et gd martinique
et qui sont venus justement essayer les
produits à montréal dans mon restaurant
au moins les changes a fonctionné les
deux les deux échangeurs fonctionner je
vous dirais que là la clientèle
québécoise une cliente est quand même
très curieuse
donc ça fait en sorte que justement
qu'on fasse qu'on amène d'autres série
culinaire le monde sont toujours
intéressés de découvrir le fait qu'il
ait une semaine martinique d'un françois
que plus en plus de restaurants y
participent que le monde sont justement
plus en plus actifs par rapport à ça
donc le mans sont curieux de savoir ce
que seront les nouveautés de l'année
avec tel ou tel restaurant qui participe
donc c'est quand même 15 août est qui et
qui toujours le fun à travailler parce
qu'on a des beaux produits en martinique
des belles robes chics et en même temps
un bon savoir faire au québec par
rapport à la cuisine donc on met les
deux ensembles ont fait en sorte de
mettre ceux d'avant donc le la clientèle
qu'on reçoit qui est justement change
aussi par rapport à son aussi beaucoup
qui en martinique est ensuite les
québécois qui sont intéressés s'avancer
que tout le monde peut découvrir le menu
qu'on propose